my wife told me that she almost broke up
with me while we were dating but four
anniversaries later and two beautiful
kids clearly she did not break up with
me the story of my first visit to meet
her parents came up and she said that
that night was almost the end for us
because her mom made meatloaf and I
barely ate any of it there's definitely
a soul here is it me for not extra
trying to choke down more meatloaf or my
wife for openly acknowledging it was a
spot where I was set up to fail well
it's definitely you I mean it's you 100
on on so many different levels you're
also because meatloaf is delicious like
what do you mean you don't like meatloaf
what kind of man are you this is you
have fallen for this is a branding thing
Okay the reason meatloaf has a bad
reputation and a lot of kids don't like
meatloaf is because of the name like
meat loaf